What are your thoughts about taking Celtic's salt?
You've got to be careful with any salt.
So remember, just because you have cancer, does it mean you don't have other issues like autoimmune issues? So in my book, I write, I think that a lot of people with cancer, there's an autoimmune component to it.
And if you go through the chronic disease in autoimmune course, you'll learn that one thing that can cause a flare of autoimmune diseases too much salt, any salt, pink salt, Celtic salt, any salt whatsoever can cause a flare of autoimmune disease in a certain group of people.
And also cause high blood pressure in a certain group of people issues too. And those are really real. I don't care, you know, what video you show me or watch that says that this certain pink salt or this family and salt or this salt is so good for you because it's kind of minerals in it and everything.
Well, the truth is it's still a salt and the minerals in there are really stone minerals or earth minerals, which are not with a kind of minerals, you're supposed to be eating anyhow, you're supposed to be eating vegetables that take earth minerals.
which are inorganic, hard solids and salts and turns it into a mineral that's double bonded to an amino acid. And then we consume that that that product, which is a vegetable, that's why the only minerals that we sell that we private label in our store are minerals that are double bonded
to amino acid, the same way that you would get them in eat by eating vegetables. So I would say I pass on that as iodine as iodine as a supplement, not a good idea to take.
Well, iodine can be helpful for people with breast cancer, but I still say only a very short term basis in general.
So if a person is taking iodine, especially as a female, you have an increase risk of creating a Hashimoto's disorder.
So iodide is necessary for my thyroid to produce T3, you say. Well, that's very true, but it's very, very small about an iodine.
If you take any iodide in a mineral supplement or iodide straight of any milligram solution, you risk increasing a stimulation on your thyroid gland and increasing a stimulation of your immune system and creating a Hashimoto's and then with a TPO antibody production or a thyroid love in an antibody production.
So long term, yes, I'd say you should hold off on that.